hi and welcome to the program naloxone
for opioid-induced respiratory
depression
my name is dr anita jacobson i am a
clinical professor at the university of
rhode island in the college of pharmacy
i am also a practicing pharmacist and
the program director of the community
first responder program which provides
harm reduction resources and naloxone
across the state of rhode island
so our learning objectives for today are
to be able to identify risk factors for
opioid-induced respiratory depression
explain the cycle of opioid use disorder
and mechanism of the opioid antagonist
naloxone commonly referred to as narcan
describe the process of responding to an
overdose including supportive care
and get into a little bit about myths
and stigma related to responding to an
opioid-induced breathing emergency
so start out with looking at some data
on opioid use and overdose nationwide
so certainly we are all well aware that
we are in the middle of an ever-growing
opioid overdose epidemic we lose over
130 americans every day
related to an opioid-involved drug
overdose and drug overdose is now the
leading cause of death among americans
under the age of 50. we also have seen
an increase in pediatric poisonings
as well as teenagers and young adults
which may be due to accidental and or
recreational exposure
so if we look at this graph that shows
the
changing dynamic in the opioid overdose
epidemic we see looking back in the late
1990s early 2000s
there was an increase in prescription
involved opioid overdose deaths i
vividly remember this time i was doing
my residencies
at the big
hospitals that are located in our state
of rhode island and i remember the drug
representatives coming on to the units
in the
trauma and surgical icus as well as the
medical floors and promoting the drug
oxycontin which is a long-acting
medication for pain
and really touting that it had low or no
addiction potential due to that long
duration of action so that there were
not the associated peaks and troughs
that we see with shorter acting opioids
and that coupled with pressure from the
joint commission to achieve zero pain
scores for patients it was considered
inhumane for people to experience pain
surrounding a procedure or surgery or
injury so those two things coupled
together really led to an increase in
prescribing and then a slow but steady
increase in prescription involved opioid
overdose deaths around 2010 we begin to
see a more precipitous rise in heroin
involved overdose deaths
this is predominantly due to a crossover
it's very rare for me to have a patient
who reports that the first opioid they
were ever exposed to was heroin
but this may be due to a switchover for
recreational use or someone who started
out with a legitim a legitimate medical
purpose and then transitions over to
heroin
and then in 2014 and 15 and 16 we see a
huge rise in synthetic involved opioid
overdose deaths and this is due and
being driven by illicitly manufactured
fentanyl
so this slide shows equally potent
amounts of heroin
fentanyl and then an
analog of fentanyl car fentanyl which
sometimes have that has been popularly
referred to as an elephant tranquilizer
and you can see that it's a much much
smaller amount of fentanyl equivalent to
a much larger amount of heroin and then
a single granule of the powerful analog
car fentanyl
you can also see that these substances
are white they're granular they they
really look the same so someone who's
using unregulated substances
like cocaine
like heroin like counterfeit tablets
would really not have any idea that
fentanyl or one of its potent analogs is
in that unregulated product
so i'd like to get into a little bit
about the concepts of tolerance and
dependence and how they interplay with
opioid overdose risk
so just as a review i actually find it
very helpful when i meet with
particularly caregivers and families of
someone who's struggling with substance
use disorder just to give them
a little review i actually will pull
this slide up on my computer screen
because people have often heard the term
opioid but really actually don't know
which medications are and are not
opioids and which substances are and are
not opioids and there's a lot of
misinformation that you know is
circulating in the world so i think it's
very helpful to go through and kind of
teach
caregivers and and family members and
friends about these different opioids
their different potencies and so our
strong opioid agonists morphine fentanyl
methadone heroin hydromorphone or
dilated oxycodone and the pyridine
i do stress with people that methadone
is unique in that it has a long duration
of action and a sealing effect so we can
get people stable on a dose for months
years even sometimes decades is needed
and they can it can help them with their
cravings get their life back in order if
they were previously addicted to a
substance like illicitly manufactured
fentanyl or heroin
and it's a very useful treatment tool
for opioid use disorder
the more moderate opioid agonists
codeine which they might be familiar
with in cough and cold preparations and
hydrocodone some more unusual opioid
agonists tramadol which has some
serotonergic activity as well and then
dextromethorphan which until recently
was available over the counter without
even age restrictions but now you know
we do have
some age restrictions in place
but i do remember practicing in
community pharmacy and finding bottles
littering the parking lot at the end of
my shift of
consumed
robitussin dm or nyquil that had
dextromethoraphan because people are
trying to get a hallucinogenic effect
and then the partial opioid agonist
buprenorphine
commonly called suboxone which is also a
useful tool for opioid use disorder and
then the opioid blockers so we're going
to be talking a lot about naloxone or
narcan but then naltrexone is available
as a long-acting injection also to treat
opioid use disorder can be a little more
tricky to get people onboarded due to
the fact that they have to be off of
opioids for two weeks prior to starting
naltrexones that can be a harder
onboarding
so i do also spend time talking to
family members and caregivers and
friends about how opioids work in the
central nervous system not really
getting into the new kappa and delta
receptor detail but just talking about
how
for specific individuals who
have a propensity
for addiction about 20 to 25 percent of
the population with exposure to opioids
they will experience a profound euphoria
so all of us may experience the pain
relief aspects of opioids but not
everyone experiences the same amount of
euphoria and pleasure
and for a percent of the population they
will go on to misuse opioids even if
they are exposed for a legitimate
medical reason and it winds up being
about 10 to 12 percent of the population
who will go on to misuse opioids
and continue for a year later after even
a short-term exposure we don't fully
understand all the environmental and
genetic factors that play into that but
it helps people to get out of the cycle
of blaming someone for addiction when
you really talk about how this happens
in the central nervous system
it's also important to explain tolerance
so as people use opioids for any reason
either recreationally or for a medical
reason
over time that repeated exposure will
cause a desensitization of the receptors
and it will take more and more opioid to
create the same effect whether that's
pain relief or whether it is euphoria
what happens with time is that when
people are taking opioids and have a
high tolerance they may be consuming
very large amounts an amount that would
be fatal to someone who is opioid naive
similar to alcohol we see that with and
i usually use that analogy with
people to help them understand that
someone who's never had an alcoholic
drink before might get
tipsy or drunk with a very small amount
compared to someone who consumes alcohol
regularly and that can sometimes help
people understand that concept
so what happens is when people stop
using an opioid if they were using it
for a long period of time the receptors
do return to baseline relatively quickly
so if they are perhaps incarcerated or
in rehab
and then are discharged into the
community and start using a substance
again
if they take the same amount that they
could previously tolerate it now might
be enough to cause an opioid overdose
and breathing emergency
physical dependence also happens with
everyone who is exposed to opioids and
is different than psychological
dependence so the body becomes dependent
on the opioid and people may experience
withdrawal symptoms to varying degrees
depending on how much and how long they
were using opioids and those withdrawal
symptoms are very unpleasant for people
i have had patients describe it to me
as the worst
like the worst stomach bug they've ever
had in their life the worst influenza
they've ever had in their life with a
whole bunch of anxiety sprinkled over
the top of that
and it's something that they
are quite desperate to avoid going
through again it's a very unpleasant
process
so how do people move from the use of
prescription opioids to heroin it's
usually due to cost and access issues so
maybe easier to get heroin on the street
unregulated
and the cost is often lower
the percent of people at risk for
developing an opioid use disorder is
about 20 20 20 to 25 percent of the
population have a vulnerability but we
do find that about half of those will
kind of self-select out maybe due to
positive environmental factors family
support education other you know
environmental factors and don't don't go
on to pursue that and about 10 to 12
percent will
and the driving factor for continued
opioid misuse
is really described in the cycle here
that that desire for that feeling of
euphoria loss of control using larger
and larger amounts due to tolerance
spending your time your effort your
money uh to get that next dose and
really withdrawal is the major driving
factor that fear of withdrawal and that
desperation to avoid going into
withdrawal for people who
have become dependent
so we consider opioid use disorder and i
advocate for patients and their families
to consider it
a chronic condition the same way we
think of asthma or diabetes or high
blood pressure
and that we want to have evidence-based
treatment that includes
certainly behavioral aspects and
components and environmental supports as
well as pharmaceutical treatment which
might be methadone buprenorphine or
naltrexone
so looking specifically at overdose risk
factors and naloxone
so i like to talk about overdose with
people who are using prescription
medications as a breathing emergency i
find my patients who are taking pain
medications
are resistant to talking about their
risk of overdose and are more receptive
when i refer to it as a breathing
emergency and that's accurate because
when you have too much opioid in the
bloodstream
the overdose is characterized by
respiratory depression which leads to a
lack of oxygen and ultimately death if
no intervention is made
so looking at our patients who have the
highest risk of experiencing overdose
here are some of the risk factors but we
certainly advocate for anyone who is
taking
certainly unregulated opioids they
should have narcan naloxone
at home and know how to use it and know
how to give it to someone else and have
someone else who can administer it to
them and really anyone taking a
prescription opioid for any reason
should have naloxone available as well
never knowing who might get into
their medications or what other factors
might happen but these are some of the
highest risk categories so people who've
gone back to use after losing their
tolerance as we talked about before if
they've had a previous non-fatal
overdose if they're using high doses or
long-acting formulations
using any unregulated substances alone
is a high risk
mixing of opioids with anything else
that is sedating so sedating
antidepressants alcohol certainly
benzodiazepines the red flags should be
going off with that
but anything sedating gabapentin
benadryl you know the list goes on
compromised health conditions
particularly lung related so pneumonia
influenza covid acute illnesses sleep
apnea copd asthma emphysema and then
liver or kidney conditions due to a lack
of metabolism and excretion
so there can be a buildup of opioid in
the bloodstream
so naloxone is used to reverse an opioid
overdose it is a prescription medication
it is non-addictive it only works on
opioids so if there's multiple
substances in someone's system
it's only acting on the opioid component
and it can help to restore their
breathing
lay people can give it as a nasal spray
or for some can do an intramuscular
injection i have some where they're very
uncomfortable with that and some
people who are who are quite confident
with it
the effect has an onset of two to three
minutes and a duration of 30 to 90
minutes very safe and we are seeing that
sometimes there are multiple doses of
naloxone required this may be due to the
potency of illicitly manufactured
fentanyl
but it also might be due to
people's lack of objectivity when they
are administering naloxone they have
someone in front of them who is not
breathing who is turning blue
they may rapidly administer doses of
naloxone in succession so it's difficult
to tease out why people are using more
and more naloxone
so naloxone literally works by
antagonizing and pushing the opioids off
the receptors and preferentially binding
it doesn't remove the opioid from the
system
so the person may go back into an
overdose situation
after 30 to 90 minutes when the naloxone
wears off it also may precipitate
withdrawal and the severity of that
really varies from person to person and
also in the amount of naloxone
administered so administering multiple
doses of naloxone is going to
potentially worsen withdrawal
and that really unpleasant experience
for people
so we do have of course an expiration
date on naloxone and we want to be
mindful of that and get a new one when
it's getting close to the time
however it does not become toxic so if
all you have is an expired product any
naloxone is better than no naloxone it
should be stored at room temperature
there are some excursions permitted so
people living in climates that are
hotter or
colder you know something to consider if
you have to keep it in a car which is
not ideal
perhaps keep it in a soft or hard sided
cooler to to protect it from extremes of
temperature
so for overdose assessment and response
this is a quote from the former surgeon
general jerome adams if we want to make
a dent in this overdose epidemic we need
everyone to consider themselves a first
responder we need to look at it the same
way we look at cpr and we need everyone
carrying naloxone and this is really
how we named our program the community
first responder program and this is the
philosophy that we've carried forward
with community distribution
so to evaluate for
there are a few steps i'm going to go
through on the next slide but once
you've determined
that someone's unconscious certainly
calling 9-1-1 needs to be that first
step administer naloxone if you have it
available if you have two people you can
have one person call 911 and one person
give the naloxone you give another dose
after two to three minutes if the person
is not responsive to that first dose you
can support their ventilation
and you know stay with that person
throughout the experience
so overdoses can happen within minutes
they can happen to someone who's opioid
naive so their first ever experience or
it can happen when they've been taking
opioids for many years or even decades
the person the key thing is that they
will be unresponsive so if someone is
intoxicated on opioids maybe slurring
their words they have pinpoint pupils
they're groggy
you know you certainly want to watch
them and stay with them but that would
not be the time to administer naloxone
this is for someone who is unresponsive
even to taking the knuckles of your hand
and rubbing it firmly on their breast
bone
then you know you know they are
unconscious because that's quite
uncomfortable
they may have slow or no breathing or it
may sound like they're snoring they may
become pale and they may start to have
signs of hypoxia with their fingernails
or lips turning blue
so how to give naloxone nasal spray
which i find is the easiest for lay
people i've done some education on the
naloxone intramuscular for lay people
and it's often harder unless they have
some experience with
doing injections but with the nasal
spray it's really quite easy so people
remove the device from the package only
when they're ready to use it hold it
with the thumb on the bottom of the
plunger and the first and middle fingers
on either side of the nozzle
tilt the person's head back supporting
the neck and insert the nozzle into the
nostril
then you depress the plunger firmly and
each of these devices is a one-time use
you can also provide ventilatory support
and or cpr depending on whether or not
the person has a pulse because opioid
overdose is predominantly a breathing
emergency it is not uncommon for someone
to have a pulse so you would not want to
do chest compressions if that's the case
but depending on how long it's been
going on they may
need compression cpr and this is really
dependent on your level of training and
comfort and i spend a lot of time with
families and caregivers talking about
this particularly in the time of covid
people may be hesitant
with a stranger or someone they don't
know to provide rescue breathing so it's
important to assure them that just
administering naloxone and calling 911
is beneficial you've done something um
and it's it's often successful upwards
of 75 percent of the time just
administering the locks in the loan
staying with the person calling 911
getting help
is effective
if someone
needs to be left for any reason perhaps
the ems can't locate you
the only time i've actually ever had to
do cpr it was in the woods and
i did have to leave the person because
the rescue couldn't find us on the
trails
so you have to roll the person into the
recovery position which is not easy to
do if it's someone who's much much
larger than you
but you want to do the best you can and
it's better with two people get them
onto their side and put the knee out to
stop them from rolling onto their
stomach with the hands supporting the
head this is to ensure if they were to
start vomiting it's going to help to
reduce their risk of aspirating and
choking
some possible naloxone responses the
first is the ideal scenario the person
starts breathing and becomes responsive
within that two to three minute window
the middle one the person starts
breathing and is groggy but not fully
responsive you would not give a second
dose of naloxone in this instance you
would watch them very closely stay with
them
but in the third scenario where they
don't respond and continue to be
unconscious then you would administer
that second dose of naloxone and again
you know time sort of loses all
perspective when you're in this very
high stress environment so when i'm
educating people on this i ask them to
set a phone timer if they can because
the instinct is after 30 seconds you're
like that has to be three minutes and
you know time really does lose
perspective in those high stress
scenarios
so some efforts to address the crisis
that you know going beyond naloxone so
our program is focused in harm reduction
so it's the public health effort to
minimize the harm associated with people
who use unregulated substances
so there are a lot of valuable resources
out there some that are listed on the
bottom of your screen the north american
needle exchange network at nasan.org
treatment locator defined methadone
buprenorphine and naltrexone providers
at findtreatment.gov
and harm reduction resources by mail
at
nextdistro.org so these are some great
resources nationwide you can search by
zip code or
state or town
and find resources near you we do
distribute fentanyl test strips with our
program it's important that people know
that these are just a tool they are not
100 accurate they are designed to help
detect fentanyl and its analogs in
unregulated substances like cocaine
heroin or counterfeit pills
and this is done by testing a residue a
small portion of finely
ground up powder that then cannot be
used after it's been in contact with the
fentanyl strip dilute with water hold
the wavy end of the test strip into the
substance
and then after a couple of minutes
you'll see the test results and it's
important to educate people that one
line is positive for fentanyl and two
lines means fentanyl earth's analogs
wasn't detected but still need to use
caution always have naloxone always have
someone with you if you're using
unregulated substances who can give the
naloxone you can always go slow use 10
percent of what you think you might need
you can always add more but you can't
take it away once it's been ingested
so people are often worried about their
liability so all 50 states do have civil
and criminal immunity for good faith
efforts of administering naloxone and
trying to help someone who's having a
medical emergency experiencing an
overdose and this provides protection to
people who seek that medical assistance
by calling 911 performing rescue
breathing or compressions and
administering naloxone
in some states there is more protection
than others so in some states people
cannot be charged
for drug or paraphernalia possession
if they are helping someone in an
overdose and that may be used as a
mitigating factor in criminal
prosecution
it's important to know your individual
state's good samaritan law because
they're not federal so they do differ
widely
in all 50 states
there is also
standing orders available in pharmacies
so that people can go into a pharmacy
and request naloxone without a specific
prescription and the labeling
requirements do vary by state so some
allow more anonymous
and some you do have to have your name
on the label
in some states health insurers including
medicaid are actually required to cover
the cost of naloxone some even
including a copay and some might be
without the copay and again that does
vary a little bit by state but in all 50
states you can go into a pharmacy and
get naloxone
on request dispensed to you but there
may be a cost associated with that
so to wrap up i'd like to look at some
myths and stigma
things that i commonly hear when i'm out
at tabling events providing resources in
the community
so the first one being is methadone or
buprenorphine just trading one addiction
for another and this is something that i
even hear
sometimes in recovery spaces aa
and others might some people might have
strongly held views here and because
methadone or buprenorphine have that
effect of being abe of being able to
titrate someone to a stable dose for
months years decades to control cravings
they don't need larger and larger
amounts to create the same results
we don't consider someone being addicted
to methadone or buprenorphine when they
are receiving that treatment and it
really
is very valuable in helping people get
their life back in order handle
different aspects
legal financial whatever you know things
they might have done damage to when they
were actively using unregulated
substances and so
we also find that the relapse rate is
quite high for people who do not use
medications to help them
treat their opioid use disorder so i
like to draw the analogy to insulin for
diabetes and that sometimes helps
families understand you know we don't
pressure people with diabetes to come
off of their insulin
and so we don't need to pressure people
who have the condition of opioid use
disorder to come off of their methadone
or buprenorphine
what if i administer too much naloxone
or isn't an overdose
with the nasal spray you don't
necessarily need to worry about
administering too much naloxone but you
can make someone's withdrawal worse if
you're giving them dose after dose
repeatedly or using a high dose
formulation so it's best to set that
timer on the phone only administer at
that two to three minute interval
and and to try to provide other support
to the person as opposed to multiple
unnecessary doses of naloxone if it's
not an overdose it won't hurt them but
it won't help them either so it is
important to still pivot you know maybe
they're having a heart attack or maybe
they're having a reaction to diabetes
medicines you want to look for medical
alert tags and other cues you don't want
to necessarily assume everything is an
overdose
well the person i give naloxone to be
combative with me when uh when they wake
up
so this has been widely exaggerated and
is a myth
people are often uncomfortable they may
swear they may
have vomiting they may feel bad
but reports of combativeness have been
widely exaggerated and it's just not
something we see
with the lay public using intranasal
naloxone
will
fentanyl test strip or naloxone
distribution enable heroin use and that
seems kind of intuitive but the data
actually shows us in the other direction
that giving out naloxone and in
communities that have robust naloxone
distribution programs we see a reduction
in er visits
for overdose and we don't see a
compensatory increase in heroin use
can i travel with naloxone absolutely
yes you can go through tsa i do it on a
regular basis with my naloxone no one
bats an eye at it is fentanyl something
i will inhale or absorb when trying to
help someone so this is another myth
that has been widely promulgated and is
very difficult to dispel
particularly among police and first
responders
but fentanyl powder is not absorbed
through the skin so it has to be done
through mucous membranes or
injected or
fentanyl patches which are specially
formulated to cross over
the subcutaneous tissue so getting dry
fentanyl powder near you is not going to
result in an overdose situation it may
be that people have panic attacks i
would panic if i got a powder on me that
i thought was going to be fatal
or it may be sometimes people covering
up their own
personal substance use and it's
difficult to tease those factors out but
it is important that people are not
scared to help someone who's
experiencing an overdose due to this
myth
so thank you so much for your time and
attention i hope you found this program
valuable
and it was a pleasure being with you
today